welcome to the 12th annual Yale any a
BPD conference today we're going to be
talking about assessing and treating
suicidality really excited to have the
lineup of speakers that we have today
they're going to be really terrific we
really appreciate them and their
willingness to come and share today I
also want to thank any a BPD for helping
us put on this conference for 12 years
it's been a wonderful working
relationship in addition to Perry
Hoffman we have several board members of
any a BPD here today we so appreciate
you coming and all the work that you do
for BPD in addition the conference is
supported by the Yale New Haven
psychiatric hospital we really
appreciate their support and everything
that gay Lemieux has done to to help us
with that we also appreciate the support
of the department of psychiatry in
holding this conference today and
finally we also wish to acknowledge our
sponsors who make this program possible
clearview treatment programs in silver
Hill Hospital please make sure to visit
their exhibitor tables in the lobby
along with our other exhibitors today
finally I want to thank the enormous
number of volunteers that helped us
actually get this together this is
entire volunteer group of individuals
not only the conference coordinators
that organize everything but our
conference staff especially Joan crica
Nicole Arabic and aleni Rodriguez have
just organized so much of this this year
and then the mini conference volunteers
you will see throughout the auditorium
today collecting your index cards and
helping you out they have volunteers on
their tags please thank them because
they have really contributed to making
this day possible next I'm going to have
Perry Hoffman the president of any appt
and co-director of the conference come
up and tell you a little bit about their
work
[Applause]
Thank You Emily and welcome to everybody
it's wonderful to think that this has
been going on for 12 years and each year
we get many more people coming so it's
thanks to the wonderful work that
Emily's done and her staff and Seth
Axelrod who really started all this I'm
not going to give many opening remarks
today and I'll tell you why in a minute
but what I'd like to do first and
foremost is to officially launch our new
website here so Todd's going to help me
get it up on the screen well this is a
labor of love of nine months of working
on a website that we hope to be
user-friendly and and your room and
access and help people more easily
access our resources we're very proud to
say that we're number two on Google so
our search engine optimization better
hold otherwise we'll start to slip so
we're praying that we we stay up there
and we hope that you'll join us on our
site and I just want to give you a
little bit of sense of what is on the
site
it's hard to use a mouse without a mouse
pad well you eating you yeah just fine
let's scroll down and if you just go to
our explore our media library okay yeah
yeah no its back its background thanks
perfect okay can you just scratch my
understand so one of the things that
we've worked most hearted at is to make
sure that all of our conference videos
we have the largest media library in the
world and what took so long to get this
site up is organizing all of our videos
that to make it more user friendly so we
hope that you'll join our site look at
it send us comments of things you'd like
to have different but we think that
you'll find it a resource not only for
yourself but if you are working of your
clinician or you're a family member
you'll find this site we hope very
valuable for all that you're doing round
borderline personality disorder so it's
now my pleasure to introduce Marie Paul
de valdivia and the reason that I've
asked her to come and do the opening
remarks is that actually Marie Paul came
to this conference seven years ago and
she came over and introduced herself to
me she's a mom of someone with the
disorder and she said you know we need
help and right away I just saw there was
a star there and so we chatted and we
started to get her up and trained to do
our family connections program which
she'll talk a little bit about she then
decided although she has her MBA and
isn't was in business she went back and
got her degree in social work from there
she had several jobs one of which at the
at the bridge which she loved and most
recently she's now back at Yale with a
faculty appointment so from those seven
years of being at this conference she's
now here as part of the year Yale
faculty and so I thought it best that
she more introduce any a BPD since she's
our executive vice president so please
welcome Repole to the devel Divya
[Applause]
thank you welcome welcome it's such a
pleasure it's a little bit like a
birthday for me here you know I was here
seven years ago and it was sort of my
first step in this direction and here we
are so welcome to the 12th year of a
wonderful collaboration between any atpg
and Yale this is the longest-running
conference continuous conference on BPG
in the world which is absolutely amazing
and it exists because of the resilience
and the dedication of dr. Hoffman who
you just met and dr. Axelrod who reached
out to dr. Hoffman 12 years ago and said
we need to do something about this and
whose dedication to reducing stigma as
well as helping people with the lived
experience of the disorder as well as
working with families and health and
Families help their patients has been
beyond none other so since then in the
past 12 years the DBT program here at
Yale has grown quite a bit again with
dr. Axelrod teaching students year after
year I was lucky enough to be one of his
students and what what an honor and a
learning experience that was so thank
you seth and and now i'm lucky enough
also to be working in the adolescent
division so dr. Axelrod's DBT sort of
leadership is spreading from the adult
area to the adolescent area and and
that's where I'm working now nea in the
past 12 years has grown enormously as
well here's a little bit of what we have
done you just heard about this website
which is an incredible resource and
regardless of whether you are a
clinician or a family member or somebody
who lives with the disorder I encourage
you to go and and look for information
in there there is a lot
there to offer other things that NEA has
been really busy with is facilitating
various conferences both in the US our
next one is in Houston in June and it is
going to be focused on early detection
and prevention and internationally our
next international conference very
exciting is in Israel towards the end of
the year so conferences we also work
hard to support other organizations who
have a similar goal as our goal so
Brandon Marshall's project 375 were
aligned with that program to help
provide family education as well as a
phenomenal organization in Canada that
has really sort of grown and exploded
they're called Sasha bear and through
Sasha bear we also offer the family
connections program we that the crown
jewel if you will of our organization is
family connections the program that
Perry alluded to family connections
served maybe a few hundred families five
years ago today we serve several
thousand families every year in the US
and in 17 countries around the globe
this class is free it is parent trained
parent lead it's a 12-week class and it
offers skills and support and psycho
education and it is evidence-based but
really the best evidence is all the
quotes and feedback we get from families
who are invariably so thankful and find
the class incredibly helpful so we teach
a lot of skills in that class and the
skills are immediately applicable to
families and help the family functioning
move forward from and I should say that
this class was developed by Perry
Hoffman by dr. Hoffman as well as dr.
frazzetti when NEA was founded so an
incredible program full-fledged NEA
affiliates have sprung over the past
10 years so there is an NEA Australia
there is an NEA Canada there's an NEA
Italy and you know they function pretty
independently but of course with our
support everybody isn't is a volunteer
in this organization quickly back to
family connections of course family
connections in all those countries also
family connections in our region so for
those of you who are family members or
who experienced the disorder and have
family members who would benefit from
the class we offer an ongoing continuous
class in White Plains and then we also
have a class two weekends a year here on
the New Haven campus thanks to the
hospitality of the hospital so in those
classes what we hear after maybe two or
three sessions is parents saying to us
if only we had known if only we had
known when they start to get the skills
and they see that it's really not that
hard it's just not very intuitive but
it's not that hard some guilt starts to
come in because you know it would have
been nice to have started doing this
when our kids were three and five and
ten but of course as parents we didn't
know so a huge and recent effort that
NEA has undertaken and is really pushing
is early detection and prevention that's
a little bit different for us it
involves talking to perhaps
pediatricians or deciding if we want to
talk with schools trying to talk with
parents in the very earlier stages of
the disease and so how do we connect to
that level many of us are really curious
about the high level of bipolar disorder
among you know that is diagnosed among
children and you know we wonder I mean
maybe it is the case and maybe a lot of
people who struggle with severe
emotional dysregulation are diagnosed
that way but could benefit from parents
and family education so that's a lot of
the work that that we're doing this and
as a final point we do all of this is
von
because borderline as an illness is not
receiving a lot of funds from ni-mh it
is my new to mount that most as opposed
to most other disorders mental health
disorders such as schizophrenia for
example so any a god actually it was was
able to get invited in a couple of weeks
to visit with the president of ni-mh and
we will try to make a strong case for
more funds but any kind of help in that
direction will be will be incredibly
supportive and helpful so that's the
stuff that NEA is doing I thank you so
much for being here any one of you who
is interested in volunteering please
approach Perry approached me we have
several board members here and on for a
fabulous conference this year again and
thank you to you doctor and sulfur
leading us here
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]